[Musique]
c'est un peu un reçu de caisse de
l'époque de Mésopotamie cette tablette
d'argile est vieille de 4000 ans une des
surprises que nous avait réservée Éric
Bouchard passionné d'histoire et les
bibliothécaires au collections spéciales
et livrera de l'Université de Montréal
c'est peut-être entre le gardien
justement de d'une certaine culture
l'université a été fondée en 1878
seulement mais les trésors littéraires
qu'on trouve ici proviennent de toutes
les époques c'est du 12e siècle quand
même le plus vieux manuscrit complet qui
nous est parvenu du Moyen-Âge un
document très ancien avec sa reliure
d'époque avec des aides de bois la
partie en parchemin et vous avez le
corps de l'ouvrage qui est sur papier un
manuel de d'histoire anciennes et
modernes préparer par un grand-père pour
sa petite fille donc on est en 1788
c'est ici qu'on peut conserver plus de
50 000 documents à température et taux
d'humidité contrôlée au fil des ans la
bibliothèque a été enrichie grâce à des
instituts de recherche ou des
bienfaitsteurs notables ou religieux qui
ont donné leur collection en tout elles
comptent 150 000 documents du côté
francophone c'est sans doute l'une des
très bonnes des très belles et des Très
Riches littérature architecture science
histoire bien entendu histoire du Canada
ça a été un point fort important
deux manuels de physique illustrées à la
main fait par Jacob guerrierpi un
médecin de la prairie donc qui date de
1839 à un des exemplaires originaux du
fameux Refus global de polémile bordua
on se retrouve ici dans la salle de
consultation principale de la
bibliothèque bon à savoir la
bibliothèque est accessible à tous s'ils
ont un intérêt particulier pour
consulter ils peuvent bienvenue s'ils
veulent visiter c'est les premiers mardi
de chaque mois l'idée en gros c'est de
pouvoir
démocratiser le plus possible si on veut
ces richesses documentaires des
richesses et plusieurs curiosités comme
cet almana le plus petit livre de la
bibliothèque ou bien c'est ouvrage de
prophétie qui date de 1740 et il va
jusqu'en 2023 donc en 2023 il nous
prédit un printemps qui sera froid sec
l'automne sera moitée
l'hiver sera tempéré
sachez aussi qu'un jeune prince des
bonheur devrait monter sur le trône du
royaume de France ici jean-Sébastien
Cloutier Radio-Canada Montréal